[Music]
today we turn to a vile disgusting
scumbag who goes by the name eden torres
now i'm coming on kind of strong right
in the opening but hopefully you'll
understand why as we proceed here eden
torres
is a quote unquote trans woman that is a
biological male um and a trans activist
and when i say trans activist i mean
that torres is a vicious soulless bully
who gets off on shaming and harassing
people and does it all under the guise
of activism
this is how most trans activists work
left-wing activists in general tend to
be callous and ruthless and
pathologically self-centered as we've
seen but all of the absolute worst
tendencies of left-wing activism are
brought together and consolidated among
trans activists
eden torres is a prime example torres
who is a male
went to a sonic drive-in recently now
for normal people a trip to a fast-food
drive-through has only one purpose the
most the most obvious one is you know to
get food and eat it
and then pay the price intestinally
speaking later
but for trans activists like torres
every situation and especially every
encounter with normal working-class
people
is primarily an opportunity to make
themselves into a victim and maybe as a
bonus ruin some random person's life in
the process that's what torres uh has in
mind when he he showed up to sonic and
was allegedly referred to as sir after
an employee saw his male name on his
credit card
this employee may have also noted
that torres has a male voice and a male
face and kind of connected the dots
quite reasonably
but you're not allowed to be reasonable
around people like torres and so the
sonic manager was summoned
and the camera was turned on
and the trap was set and here's how the
conversation went
that's why
i mean i'll pull and yeah and why you
want to record me because your entire
staff has been calling me sir
okay uh do you wanna park i why don't
you tell me what we can do now no
because i can do the same thing with you
okay but your entire staff has been
calling me sir
the entire time okay
what about me looks like a sir right now
okay okay
can we please move to the side no
what
look i'm sorry and i apologize for what
happened
okay if they did that or oh i mean uh
what do you want me i'm sorry what else
can i tell you i mean now
what else can i tell you
one if you're um uh
can we please move to the if i'm a what
you can move to the side if i'm away
i didn't say anything okay don't try to
put any any words in my mouth okay
okay
okay look
if they call you assert i don't know
what they did then because they saw the
name on my credit card and they were
being they were not being nice people
well i mean that's what your name in the
card guy what you want whether one what
do you want them to tell you
that has nothing to do with it
there could be someone in the back that
they don't see
that's paying okay ma'am so why would
they intentionally do that can you tell
me what your location has done to be
transcompetent because clearly they are
not
yeah this stuff i i just i wish i could
be
i wish i could witness one of these
things sometime i wish i could be there
when it happens
you know because i i would just love to
step in and say hey yeah let me uh so so
here's here's the problem here uh sir is
that you're you're a male yeah you are
do something about yeah fill me go ahead
and publicly shave me see how that works
out for you
so that is that is the answer eden um
they assume that you were a male because
you are in fact a male
and while you live every day
enveloped in your own narcissism
thinking only about yourself believing
that the world has no purpose but to
affirm you these people had other
priorities their priority in that moment
was to get you your food and move to the
next customer
and that ultimately is the great sin
they committed as far as you're
concerned they didn't bow before you and
treat you like the god or i guess
goddess that you think you are
now this exchange with the manager went
on for several minutes and um let's see
how it ended because it's kind of funny
watch this
why does it matter oh it doesn't matter
to you i'm so i mean but to me
i'm a male
okay okay so what are you so i can call
you sir or ma'am what are you
what would you assume looking at me
what are you what would you assume
looking at me
i assume that you're a man
okay
okay
thank you whatever
now there's a a very funny moment there
that you
that you miss if you're only listening
to the audio but um
eden asks the manager what sex the
manager would assume eden is by looking
at him and the manager says well you
know i'd assume you're a man he was
asked a question and he answered it and
then eden turns the camera around to his
face and i guess we're supposed to see
his face and say well that's absurd
that's clearly a woman but instead the
face only affirms the manager's response
um a response that he gave because
torres again asked for it
so you see how one trap after another is
set up the victim and the victim by this
i mean the manager is baited and baited
all while he tries his best to be polite
and accommodating
but mere politeness mere accommodation
is not enough
unquestioned immediate submissive
affirmation is the only thing that
torres will accept anything less is a
transphobic assault
torrez of course went on to publish all
these videos and tag sonic in an attempt
to get the poor guy fired sonic
responded yesterday afternoon saying
quote eden we have a strict
anti-discrimination policy and take this
very seriously we launched an immediate
investigation into the incident and we
have reached out to you via tick tock to
gather more information needed to
complete the investigation
please feel free to dm us here
i just i wish
that sonic said said something like sir
we
we have we don't tolerate discrimination
here sir
now it's not clear if the manager will
be fired but the recent history that
we've seen with these incidents would
suggest that his chances of remaining
employed are pretty slim
a corporation like sonic
they could tell torres to get lost
even better they could condemn his
actions and his bullying of their
employee and then tell him to get lost
but instead they'll probably just cave
to his demands as for the videos they
demonstrate an important point
that gender ideology more than any other
leftist doctrine
is spread and propagated by force
what you're witnessing in videos like
this is a modern form of forced
conversion
gender activists compel normal people to
affirm their doctrines under threat of
public shaming loss of income or
violence or all three in some cases
in a forced conversion centuries ago or
even today in some parts of the world
you may have been coerced into affirming
a religious doctrine under threat of
being burned at the stake
now you're coerced into affirming the
doctrines of the gender cult under a
threat of having everything else in your
life aside from your physical body
incinerated
trans activists are basically what your
public school history teacher told you
the inquisitors were the difference is
that the inquisition has been
caricatured and it was far more
defensible than modern-day cancer
culture is
especially the cancel campaign's waged
by trans activists also in in this
inquisition
of today the inquisitors are not trying
to coerce a belief in or submission to
any sort of eternal celestial god rather
they themselves are the gods
at least that's what they believe
and they want us to believe or pretend
we do
all while posturing as the victim
in an exchange that they instigate
with someone who does not want to be a
part of it
that's how the game works
and it is repulsive
and that's why today eden torres the
miserable
scumbag
is cancelled with a vengeance hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated